I'm reading this book called from
dictatorship to democracy I just
finished by Gene sharp he died four
years ago or something like that
fascinating story and he breaks down the
187 things you got to do to have a
peaceful Revolution to go from a you
know dictatorship to a democracy which
theocracy in other words that's pretty
much a dictatorship they have over there
right now you don't have a voice you
don't have freedom anything can be taken
away from it's a very different kind of
an environment but his argument is this
has to be a peaceful Revolution peaceful
protesting it can't be violent it's like
the whole story with MLK versus Malcolm
X one wanted to do it peaceful the other
one had to you know go more on the
violent uh direction do you think the
Iranian people can pull this off
peacefully or are they going to need
help for someone to support them to be
where it's going to get pretty violent
Patrick John when you get to the point
that the starting three days ago they're
taking Criminal
prisoners out yeah and give them a
weapon to fight the protesters give them
a chain to fight the protesters
regime opened the jails criminal jails
people that they killed people now they
give them promise of lowering their uh
you know jail time or often for the
death or whatever and put them in the
street there's also reports of um which
the regime in Iran has done this before
they bring in forces from Lebanon and
surrounding countries um because some
people say that it's it's easier for
them to beat and kill Iranians because
it's not there how about hands it's not
their people their country women and men
so that's happening too because there's
photos circulating of their uniforms
their videos and the videos of the
talking Arabic yeah yeah they're saying
that uh you're in my land and you're
telling me what I can do in my own
country get out of my country and
they're speaking even the police or
whatever they're not even wearing
anything some of them are just in uh
casual clothes but going back going back
to the question to all of you and you
know violent peaceful protest is is the
method of peaceful protesting can that
Prevail long term no you don't think
okay so tell me why I just feel like and
also for a diaspora Iranian to be
sitting out here I can never tell people
in Iran what to do because I'm not there
no questions yeah so what I'm just
saying is when um because I've seen
people inside of Iran say this in a more
eloquent articulate way but essentially
if you're if the state is meeting us
with repression and violence that's how
we're going to respond back and that's
what you're seeing okay fine so how do
you do that without weapons because over
there it's not Second Amendment it's not
like America where they believe in
Second Amendment which by the way times
like this kind of validates kind of need
a gun here and there to protect myself
against the government that tries to do
this to me uh but uh how do you do that
if you don't have access to guns and
weapons and that's a major problem
because people thinking army would join
them one of these days well guess what
the head of the army are selected from
the high generals of separ start on they
put him on the top of the army we heard
last week there are five of each group
higher ended the rank they got the uh
basically a sesame because they were
thinking or talking with each other for
something like that yeah here's the
point right now people they're hoping
that they get the lower rank this side
and if you see Stone and Rockies against
the tear gas and bullet people assume
the people like we the people not the
government sure okay police forces come
to their side hoping that police forces
come to their side which I believe is
one thing that a lot of people say
outside of Iran inside that that's what
they need absolutely and by the way you
know what this book said the book said
when large institutions unions
organizations turn against the
government that's when they start losing
so it's not just the people so it's like
when you're talking about businesses yes
oil things like that that's kind of the
direction it needs to go to for some of
that to be taking place but you're
saying there's regardless of what
happens it's going to go through
violence it's not going to have a it's
not going to be successful as a peace
report protein way past it so let me ask
you was the 79 one a peaceful protest
when they got the shot or was it was it
violent it was peaceful so maybe
peaceful could work because being too
violent also it worked against the Shah
Patrick John this regime is dirtier than
the Shah it's the worst regime in the
history you don't find any King any
dictator did what they did to the
country and to the people you know so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
thank you
[Music]